que Y a présent sur ce plateau Erwan
balade en bonjour et merci d'être avec
nous vous êtes députés démocrate du
Finistère alors Erwan Balan Stéphanie
Despierre a un petit peu parlé de ces de
ses moyens mais qu'allez-vous faire de
toute cette argent alors on sait qu'il y
aura des greffiers des magistrats
supplémentaires mais est-ce que vous
pouvez nous détailler pourquoi faire
finalement des moyens humains
supplémentaires ce qui ce qui est
important parce que aujourd'hui vous
l'avez dit on veut accélérer les délais
dans la justice c'est un des principales
reproches que que fait les Français ce
que font les Français sur sur la justice
et qu'elle est trop lente et pour
qu'elle aille plus vite et qu'elle
fonctionne mieux il faut des moyens
humains donc 1500 magistrats 1500
greffiers c'est inédit c'est énorme et
puis en tout 10000 personnes pour 10000
personnes des auxiliaires de justice ou
tout le la chaîne globale de la justice
pour qu'elle fonctionne mieux
c'est un mouvement qu'on a commencé il y
a 5 ans et qu'on va encore continuer
pendant quatre ans et en 10 ans on
réarmer la justice de notre pays est-ce
que ça sera suffisant je pense qu'il
faudra continuer donc c'est pas les
chances 2027 les effets se poursuivront
qu'on a commencé dès 2017 on va aller
jusqu'à
2027 et j'espère j'espère qu'on
continuera après parce que la justice
dans un pays est Cécile meilleur vient
de le dire dans une grande démocratie
c'est un des piliers c'est un des
fondamentaux d'une grande démocratie
donc voilà des moyens supplémentaires
mais aussi un certain nombre de réformes
nécessaires pour être dans l'air du
temps et dans et dans la préoccupation
d'un certain nombre d'heures et revenir
bien sûr c'est possible mais avoir
effectivement le déploiement de tous ces
moyens c'est vrai qu'il y a beaucoup de
moyens qui sont qui sont mobilisés mais
c'est aussi souvent un problème
d'organisation est-ce que ces moyens
seront véritablement bien fléchés et
bien utilisé surtout à un moment donné
quand vous avez pas les moyens ça
s'engorge et ça symb et c'est ça qu'il
faut combattre quand on visite et avec
Cécile huntermeyer je sais qu'on le fait
nos juridictions il vous disent nous
l'urgence on sait faire c'est dès qu'on
est dans des contentieux qui n'ont pas
qui nous demande pas des délais c'est là
que tout symbolise et c'est là qu'il y a
des retards qui se prennent et ça c'est
pas tolérable parce que c'est
intolérable pour des Français qui sont
en attente d'une décision qui soit
victime ou qui soit auteur il faut que
ça aille plus vite et vraiment si on met
le paquet si on organise bien on va
réussir à gérer ce qu'on appelle un
terme un peu barbare le stock pour avoir
ensuite un flux continu et pour
rattraper le retard qu'on a eu et c'est
tout l'ambition depuis maintenant 6 ans
et c'est cette ambition qu'il faut avoir
et qu'il faut continuer mais ça passe
aussi par des ajustements sur la manière
de faire et par exemple alors c'est pas
dans le texte parce que c'est du
réglementaire mais sur la question
civile il va falloir revoir aussi la
façon dont on juge les affaires civiles
pour mettre plus plus de place à la
médiation plus de place à l'accord entre
les parties pour que parfois ça aille
tout simplement plus vite et dans moins
de moins de contentieux et dans moins de
conflits entre les parties qui soient
victimes auteurs
il dit ça va pas assez loin sur la
création de place de prison vous en
prévoyez 15000 aujourd'hui il y a 60 000
détenus 73000 détenus et 60000 places
effectivement il y a cette surpopulation
carcérale et ce qu'il faut pas aller
au-delà alors 15000 c'est déjà un
chiffre important et c'est un chiffre
qui va falloir tenir et ça va pas
toujours être simple alors parce que
vous n'avez pas tenu déjà l'objectif sur
le premier quinquennat est-ce que
j'allais vous dire
c'est que parfois dans certaines dans
certains territoires et je pense par
exemple à l'Île-de-France ou vous avez
des positions de l'exécutif régional qui
qui n'encourage pas et qui n'incite pas
à trouver des solutions donc premier
point après
ce que dit Olivier Marleix n'est pas
tout à fait vrai la justice c'est pas
que la question des prisons la justice
c'est des magistrats et des greffiers
tout un personnel judiciaire en capacité
de donner des réponses et de donner des
réponses pénales et cette idée qui est
fausse de croire que on est une justice
laxiste parce qu'il y aurait pas assez
de place de prison c'est complètement
faux c'est pas pour ça et déjà on n'est
pas pour régler
il y a deux il y a deux sujets il faut
régler la population
tout simplement parce que vous avez
aussi des questions de dignité humaine à
l'intérieur des prisons et d'échec de la
réinsertion parce que si vous êtes
détenu dans des conditions qui sont pas
des conditions dignes et qui sont pas
des conditions d'humanité vous n'avez
aucune chance de vous réinsérer à
l'issue de votre peine la prison c'est
pas une condamnation à vie pour les gens
qui sont condamnés c'est une
condamnation pour payer à la société le
mal qu'ils ont pu faire le mal qu'ils
ont pu faire à des victimes mais aussi
préparer la suite et préparer la
réinsertion les gens qui sont en
récidive c'est de la double peine pour
tout le monde et donc c'est un sujet et
si on fait 15000 places de prison c'est
tout simplement pour pour avoir des
établissements qui sont dignes qui sont
corrects mais à côté de ça il faut aussi
travailler sur un certain nombre de
sujets d'alternatives à la peine et
c'est ce qui avait dans notre texte
parce que tout le monde n'est pas n'a
pas vocation à aller en prison il y a
des peines qui parfois sont bien plus
efficaces le tige le travail d'intérêt
général par exemple qui permet dans
beaucoup de situations de casser le
petit tag de te délinquance dès le début
et puis de réinsérer quelqu'un il faut
pas avoir cette vision très dichotomique
de la prison voilà et un autre sujet
sans vouloir faire polémique les moyens
de la justice sous la période justement
avant Sarkozy et Sarkozy ont été la
variable d'ajustement et on se souvient
du plan de Rachida Dati qui était une
véritable saignée pour notre justice et
qu'on paye en partie aujourd'hui
bondir là vous avez entendu cette député
les filles elles disent c'est une
atteinte aux droits fondamental c'est
une dérive totalitaire mais moi je veux
bien qu'on fasse peur aux Français mais
là je vais entendre des des bêtises
enfin je suis désolé je reste poli elle
vient de dire que c'est déjà possible
non c'est pas possible aujourd'hui le
juge ne peut pas utiliser la
géolocalisation premier point deuxième
point on va le rendre possible pour un
certain nombre d'affaires pour les pour
la justice non voilà c'est pas possible
on va le rendre possible ce qui est
possible c'est de géolocaliser soit avec
un bornage c'est-à-dire vous avez les
trois bornes vous mettez une borne
pardon sur la voiture par exemple soit
par un bornage avec trois antennes on
sait mais c'est pas précis on sait que
ça marche pas c'est compliqué là ce
qu'on veut rendre possible c'est pour
les délits au dessus de 5 ans la
possibilité de géolocaliser ça peut
avoir des intérêts incroyables sur les
enlèvements d'enfants sur le suivi de
proxénétisme sur tout un tas d'affaires
qui sont un des affaires qui sont de
moyenne intensité ensuite il y a un
deuxième sujet qui est le sujet des
écoutes par les téléphones portables
écoute et utilisation des caméras des
téléphones portables là on est de la
très haute intensité et ce qui s'appelle
les techniques spéciales d'enquête c'est
pour la criminalité organisée et c'est
pour le terrorisme on est très loin
d'une surveillance de masse on a vu les
juges d'instruction les juges
d'instruction sont quand même en
audition nous ont dit que les gens
n'aient pas peur c'est une dizaine sauf
que les ONG beaucoup d'avocats aussi on
s'est mis parce que des craintes et des
garanties que les garanties sur liberté
individuelles n'étaient pas mais on a
cette préoccupation moi je suis un grand
défendeur des libertés individuelles
mais là on est l'utilisation très
encadrée avec des délais qui sont des
délais plus courts que ce qui existe
maintenant
avec l'autorisation d'un d'un magistrat
qui permet qui donne l'autorisation ou
non au procureur de l'utiliser on a tout
une série de garde-fous après moi je
partage et on en a discuté un certain
nombre de préoccupations peut avoir
madame Cécile winter Mayer c'est sur le
suivi de ces mesures il va falloir qu'on
les suive et il va falloir que nous
parlementaires nous fassions notre
travail d'évaluation et de contrôle de
l'action des pouvoirs publics sur ces
questions là mais on est très très loin
de la surveillance de masse il faut et
surtout il faut pas dire n'importe quoi
il faut pas faire peur aux Français et
juste pour conclure les avocats avaient
une crainte on a réglé ses craintes par
la destruction des bandes de toutes les
bandes qui auraient été enregistrées
dans des conditions que l'on a défini
impossible aujourd'hui très rapidement
c'est ce qu'on a fait dans le texte et
Cécile huntermeyer le sait bien c'est
sous autorisation du JLD que pourra être
donné l'utilisation de cette technique
spéciale d'enquête voilà bon ensuite je
le redis il s'agit pour le son et pour
l'image de de fait de très haute
intensité des enquêtes autour de la
criminalité organisée autour de
terrorisme qui sont des enquêtes la
plupart du temps gérés par les Gires qui
sont des des juridictions spécialisées
sur ces questions là donc franchement ne
faisons pas peur aux Français parce que
ce des techniques dont nos polices et
nos gendarmeries d'améliorer
d'attraper des gens qui sont par exemple
sur le très grand banditisme les
systèmes mafieux les systèmes
terroristes enfin c'est pas rien et
aujourd'hui ils sont beaucoup plus forts
que nous parce qu'ils utilisent déjà eux
ces techniques et ils savent les
détourner parfaitement il faut que nos
enquêteurs et les moyens de se mettre à
niveau ce courrier a donc été signé par
votre président de groupe Jean-Paul
Mattei comme Laurent Marc Angelico
horizon et Aurore berger pour
Renaissance qu'est-ce qu'il a motivé
est-ce qu'il faut aller plus loin que ce
qui avait déjà écrit dans une lettre la
présidente moi je pense que il y a sa
trouble un peu tout le monde cette
présence la liberté de manifester et
constitutionnelle elle est importante
mais quand on est parlementaire à des
moments de troubles et à des moments
difficiles suite à un moment où le pays
a eu des émeutes c'est à chacun
d'appeler à la responsabilité et je
crois pas que c'était leur place d'être
à cette manifestation à ce moment-là et
donc vous souhaitez des sanctions c'est
ce qui est écrit dans le courrier euh ça
doit être mis à l'ordre du jour pour
vous du bureau mercredi prochain moi je
vais laisser le bureau faire ses choix
le bureau est souverain des sanctions je
sais pas mais que chacun se pose un peu
des questions et ce se posent la
question là de sa responsabilité et du
poids qui peut avoir vis-à-vis de jeunes
vis-à-vis de gens qui aujourd'hui dans
un trouble parfois qui peut être
compréhensible suite à cette à ce à ce
décès dramatique de cet enfant je crois
qu'il faut appeler au calme et appeler
plutôt à essayer de trouver des
solutions dans le dans le j'ai envie de
dire dans une sérénité nécessaire et je
ne suis pas sûr qu'elle est à des
manifestations interdites soit la
meilleure des réponses mais je le redis
et ça c'est une conviction forte que
j'ai le droit de manifester dans notre
pays et constitutionnel